i mean what's like a famous like what's
like a show that is
like not universally praised but it's
like not like
it's not like ghazi's wing or like mars
destruction where like the only reason
why it's known is because it's bad
i don't know because i here's the thing
if there's a bad anime
i'm likely not to watch it or finish it
right
because okay here's his thing if
something's as bad as ghazi's wing
or something then i'm gonna finish it
but i still think it's good because it
gives me
some kind of entertainment value right
yeah what i don't like the worst thing
an anime can do for me is just be boring
it's
be mid not gonna lie go to high school
kind of [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] oh he said i'm gonna say it
oh he's kind of [ __ ]
you mean god of mid school yeah i i'm
when i made a tweet about rent a
girlfriend there was like
three people who were like yo god of
high school is the best anime this
season i'm like what season are you
watching
watching god of high school just makes
me so disappointed
i'm like the disappointed dad because i
look at some of these fight scenes
and i still think choreography and
animation wise
it's probably some of the best fight
scenes you can find all year so far i
can't think of a better anime yeah i
think i
think we've said like that it's pretty
[ __ ] it's just disappointing it was so
popular yeah yeah
and i don't know i i've heard from from
a lot of web uh
webtoons readers that it basically
skipped through
everything and just gave you the fights
um that's not how to do it
exactly but i mean it just gave me the
feeling of just i don't know watching
like a very good
you know fight animation on like youtube
or something where you know
you you have these fight scenes and it
would have worked better
being clipped and put onto youtube with
no context then it would
have been in like that that's what i
watched like because i didn't i didn't
actually watch the anime i just saw the
clips on youtube and i'm like oh there's
some cool fight scenes but
is it enough for me to get invested into
the show probably not i watched like
10 episodes of naruto like last year why
because i wanted to get into like first
season yeah like as kids naruto
yeah yeah like the very oh okay and that
was horrible because
i was like oh my god even the story
feels like filler
yeah that's why i never got into naruto
yeah and like i'm watching this and i'm
10 episodes in and i'm like
nothing has happened we've like left the
village
and and we've done like i've watched
more opening and ending than i have
like show development and then they did
that annoying shonen thing which i think
should be like
it should be illegal you should be put
in prison if you do it where you put
four minutes of the previous episode
at the start of the episodes after the
intro so it's only six minutes
of like like [ __ ] that you've already
seen and don't need to see
like in the industry we call that and we
kept syndrome yeah and then 14 minutes
the actual episode yeah and then like
seven minutes outro somehow they find a
way to drag it out the last like six
arcs and one piece is that yeah that's
i was about to say i don't know how
there are still anime only watches of
one piece
when that is that was like literally
every episode for
the past six years i remember the last i
watched in one piece was the punk hazard
arc and literally every [ __ ] episode
was like
here's an extended opening and then 10
minutes of filler
five minutes of actual content and then
an extended ending
it's cause there's only one they only
adapt like one chapter per episode
and you know granted the chapters are
dense as [ __ ]
you compare the chapters today of one
piece to like some of the early chapters
and it's it's like they like oda added
like a light novel into his chapters
in between these like there's so much
dialogue and it's so
small and it's so concentrated but um
yeah i mean it still doesn't it still
doesn't add up to like one entire
anime episode worth of content in my
opinion no um
so yeah we read the manga of one piece
which why should i go
it's too long gone it's it's too [ __ ]
big there's the worst argument i've ever
heard what does it mean
i don't wanna it's like why don't you
get a degree connor it's only four years
come on man
why aren't you doing this it's so good
for you i got a degree i think it was
[ __ ]
okay but yeah but if you enjoy the
degree okay what if there's this really
good thing
right did you want it to like end
quickly no
or do you want it to keep going on for
as long as possible
because that's one piece right like yo
you're talking about it like it's a
commitment yeah if you're into what it
is
like you could say the same thing about
jojo i guess yeah but at least jojo
there's like parts so you can like
yeah well the one piece there's arcs
like parks are different to parts though
i don't know man i stopped at the punk
hazard arc and and i could easily go
back to it
i i wouldn't feel comfortable stopping
mid-arc no no no no no no no no
sorry between arcs i wouldn't feel
comfortable no no but that's why i ended
until the arc was over
to like take a break yeah but i wouldn't
feel comfortable doing that why because
it's
the same show it's the same characters
they're still doing this adventure i'm
not finished
i can't just stop it doesn't matter
because you're gonna get shown in recap
syndrome at the beginning of the next
one anyway oh my god
so it doesn't matter it's just i think
the thing is is because it's also
daunting for the fact that
if i get into it it's great that there's
that much
but it's also terrifying that there's
that much but that's the thing right
like you're you're saying it
in the the pretense of like oh i'm
probably not going to enjoy one piece
right
now i'm saying what's worrying is if i
do enjoy your eyes because
i'm not gonna get anything done for like
five years i'm gonna be there just
[ __ ] reading about how luffy's arms
are ripped off by
stretching it with john i actually like
i completely get what you're saying
because i was
i was having this thought experiment of
if i wasn't already into one piece
would you get into could i convince
could it could future me or could like
no i could could could like convince an
alternate universe of me
who hasn't seen one piece to now get
into one piece and i'm like
that is so [ __ ] difficult i don't
know how i would convince myself to get
into one piece
but i mean my schedule was already
pretty rammed with
not reading manga yeah and the manga i
do get to read is
very small parts and i wouldn't want to
read something because i i don't read
several manga in one go right i read
one manga at a time yeah yeah i read it
all i go into the next right yeah and i
don't know why my brain just can't i
don't really enjoy
because i'm i'm i'm exactly so i get
that i'm exactly the same as connor when
i'm
into something when i'm into something
has to be that i i am into something no
i get that
i i literally lost [ __ ] two days of
doing nothing because
i caught up to rent a girlfriend and
that was just like my obsession for that
two days right if friends girlfriend was
like 500
500 chapters i would have just lost like
oh yeah yeah
i i dedicated like an entire month to
just reading barky like how many
chapters of uh
like but like one pieces there almost a
thousand yeah but like
on on the flip side on the flip side i
really value that
because it's it's so like part part of
me as like
part of me of like has who is someone
who has been an anime and manga fan for
so long
i i kind of miss the feeling like you
had as a kid where you could just lose
an entire week to just
to just watching this anime because is
it like
is it i'm either are you guys the same
way it's like so hard for you to like
marathon stuff now
yeah yeah like especially if it's like
over 12 episodes yeah it's really hard
for me i'm like
it's really hard for me to marathon
something but that's why when i'm
like into a show and i'm like properly
into it and i'm just losing days
i really [ __ ] value that yeah and i i
search for it wherever i can but it's
so hard for me to find yeah even if
there's like technically a
good show or a good series which i can
say yeah this this is a good show
i felt really [ __ ] good like when i
finally marathon demonstrator in like
two days yeah i was like damn i haven't
felt
this couldn't i actually finished a show
that was more than twelve episodes what
the [ __ ] yeah
i missed i missed the feeling of just
having [ __ ] days and time past yeah
you're not like
well you're not like i was discussing
what's what sucks to be a [ __ ] adult
but like i will say that if if you do
want that feeling just get into one
piece
i'm 1000 chapters doesn't sound
that bad like i read all of eye shield
there's more volumes of jojo than there
is one piece
letting you know is there more chapters
of oh i guess there's technically more
yeah i mean yeah
i read five through seven of jojo's in
like i think
uh just over a week yeah yeah oh yeah
you could you could easily get from like
the alabaster without
like the mermaid that was like a week of
me sitting in my bed with a cup of tea
non-stop just like
well that's the thing right it's like if
you get into it then it won't really
matter yeah but that's the problem is
that i'm gonna lose three weeks of my
life
minimum yeah but you're gonna enjoy
those three you're gonna remember those
three weeks of your life and you're
you're gonna look well i have to show
for it and then you'll finally be able
to
come jump into a conversation about one
piece and being like yeah
if there was like an xbox like a
real-life xbox achievement where you can
be like i've read one piece
and you could have like this badge that
says you've read one piece and it's like
my driving license
how much free time do i have it kind of
varies i guess on the day because like
some and we're youtubers right so some
days i'm
working [ __ ] all day non-stop some
days i'm i'm sitting there
trying to think of a video idea and
nothing happens and i just didn't do
anything all day
yeah i play the game of league maybe i
don't know but
like if i read something it's so hard to
see that as like uh i'm not the type of
person who reads casually it's like if i
read
i need to like focus and decide that i'm
going to read and it'd be a long thing
i can't just be like yeah i'll read a
chapter for five minutes again
there's people i know who can pick up a
book read two pages and be like
nice that was good i'm going to do the
rest i'm like what yeah
what that's like that's like getting a
semi and being like at a good wank
i need like a minimum of like five
chapters to fully get myself
in like the reading zone yeah and then
once i'm in that zone i'm like okay
don't talk
to me yeah yeah exactly it's it's it's
like that sense of flow you know what i
mean it's
it but i don't understand people who can
like read a book and watch a movie at
the same time yeah that doesn't
like have the tv on in the background on
the background
i need complete silence to read oh yeah
that's because like every time on like
aki's story
she comes into you read it manga you're
like what woman yeah and it's like
there's no there's no noise
woman i mean i need my total piece
book i'll just draw a coloring book